so the question is from Megan Wisconsin
Dave Chris I'm currently on baby steps
to paying off my debts I have federal
student loans which I've been paying a
minimum on all surplus money I have has
gone to the for smaller debts than the
student loans so far however with kovat
the monthly payments are not due my
question is should I make the payment
even though it's not due and then go on
the smallest debt and then the last
remaining credit card the others are
paid off and then start back on the
student loans mmm I mean Dave as I look
at that what we've been dramatically
consistent in telling people is if your
income and hours have not changed
continue to make your payments and
continue to make that progress on that
thing and get it out of your life it
won't really matter if you continue with
gizelle intensity on this mathematically
here's what's gonna happen
if you pay $50 on your student loan that
you didn't have to right now that
reduces what you put on the credit card
by $50 so you're staying debt a little
bit longer on the credit card hmm but
your when you get to the student loan it
will have been reduced by that $50 right
if instead you just follow what the
government says and say I'm gonna pay
minimum payments required which will be
nothing right now on the student loans
I'm gonna go and put the $50 and speeds
up knocking out the credit card but of
course you had introduced the student
loan right but so at the end of the day
you will have paid the $50 one way or
another one direction of the other so
it's not it doesn't cost you any money
to go one direction or the other or even
anytime it's just a matter of the way
you feel about it so I always said we
always say and Chris just said Chris is
right we've always been dramatically
consistent pay the minimum payment
allowed and in this case the minimum
payment allowed is you're not required
to make a student loan payment no
payments no interest until October no
federally insured student loans so that
will accelerate how fast you knock out
the others and then you'll get to this
but if you want to make the minimums
what your old minimums on there you can
do that to either one of those would be
within the guidelines or what we teach
but the concept being that you don't
just go oh I don't have any student loan
payments so I'm gonna do nothing
yeah now that would be dumber than a
rock it really would and in September
Dave when this moratorium goes away
we'll have people that are in pavement
shock yeah they really are
yeah come back on the comeback if you
haven't if you're but if you're working
a plan you see it coming you know what's
gonna do you're gonna be just fine
either direction mathematically now
that's a lot different than skipping a
payment on your house cuz you're not
really skipping a payment there that
payments waiting on that is so true baby
they're waiting on you at the end or in
September and we're not doing that it is
not a mortgage ferry there's no such
thing I talk about this in Financial
Peace University and the real estate
lesson you all have heard me say that no
mortgage ferry there you go